social anxiety I want people to think
about it is your body's telling you that
you're not safe because you're
constantly under surveillance you're
being judged people are examining you
people are watching you right in the
nerd world we call this a negative
examination the world is looking at you
and they don't like what they see and
you're never going to measure up to a
particular situation and in some case uh
like with social anxiety disorder you
can never measure up with other people
and that makes being around other people
exhaust s and over time you just get
sick of being exhausted all the time and
so you end up slowly withdrawing or
finding ways around groups of people or
dealing with people alog together even
if you have a a skill set in an area or
a passion in an area it's not worth um
feeling like you're on display and that
everyone's judging that display um